I bet the raccoon didn't have to climb a
mountain.
Technically he's not a raccoon.
Whatever, he eats garbage.
Welcome
Natasha daughter of Ivan.
Clint son of Edith.
Who are you?
Consider me a guide to you and
to all see the soul stone. Oh good.
You tell us where it is then we'll be on our
way
If only it were that easy.
How's it going?
Maybe he's making this sh*t up.
No
I don't think so.
What, cause he knows your daddy's name?
I didn't/
And after everything happened with shield
During my little hiatus I went back to Russia
and tried to find my parents
Two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence.
I pulled some weeds and left some flowers.
We have what we have when we have it.
Clint?
Says he's retired.
Wanda?
TBD.
I'm off to Vienna and there
is plenty of room on the jet.
Just because it's the path of least
resistance doesn't mean it's the wrong
path staying together is more important
than how we stay together.
What are we giving up to do it?
Sorry Nat.
I can't Sign.
I know I know.
Well, then what are you doing here?
I didn't want you to be alone
We are family we fight with you.
Here's what's going to happen
Natasha don't slouch! I'm not slouching!
You're going to get the back hunch!
Listen to mother. Oh my god, enough all of
you! I didn't say anything that's not fair!
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie! This
is going to be my new Avengers infinity
Saga deleted scene video for Red Skull
the soul stone Black Widow and her
parents because there are three
different sets of parents that they talk
about in all these different scenes
Ross mark and who plays Red Skull during
infinity war in Avengers endgame even
hinted that Red Skull would be coming
back in future Marvel projects movies
and TV shows there's a bunch of Easter
eggs so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we have
a bunch of big stuff coming up I know
things are really crazy right now too so
I will give an update at the end of the
video about what's going on we're doing
an Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about the Black Widow
post-credit scene on the video so we'll
just break this down top 7 style
starting with number 7 during avengers
endgame hawkeye and black widow go to 4
mirror in the year 2014 during the
events of the first guardians of the
galaxy movie four years before annas
came with Gamora during the events of
infinity war just as Red Skull greeted
Thanos and Gamora using their father's
names
Thanos son of a Lars Gamora son of
Thanos Red Skull reveals the name of
black widows true father
Natasha daughter of Ivan then there's
the scene of the Black Widow trailer
footage showing red Guardian real name
Alexey szostak off' referring to them as
family him as her father and milena
basta cop as her mother and Yelena
Belova Black Widow refers to Natasha as
her sister in separate trailer footage
number 6 then there's the Captain
America Civil War deleted scene of Black
Widow talking to Captain America before
the events of the Black Widow movie were
even earlier in the timeline here where
she says she went back to Russia tracked
down her birth parents and lay down some
flowers to remember them on their graves
their whole conversation is about not
getting hung up on the past and what
might have been just learning
appreciate the time you have with those
people that you care about so taking all
three of these scenes from the Infinity
Saga we have a couple different sets of
families for Black Widow who is a real
family in what is going on with all the
characters during the Black Widow movie
so number five the bother that Red Skull
is talking about on Vermeer during
avengers endgame ivan is actually a
comic book reference to her first
adoptive father ivan petrovich a Russian
KGB agent from the comics who was also
part of the Red Room program he's the
one that initially found her on the
streets raised her till she was old
enough then gave her to the Red Room
Black Widow program to be trained
black widows birth father and mother are
never named in the comics you never
learned who they are she also has a
couple of biological younger brothers in
a biological older brother who were
believed to have died in a fire when she
was a baby
during that house fired Natasha's birth
mother threw her out a window to save
her and she was thought to be the only
survivor until years later she comes
back and she meets a cyborg version of
her older brother and fought him he was
a really crazy comic book story but in
the Captain America Civil War deleted
scene when she talks about visiting her
parents graves she's probably talking
about the birth parents that died in the
fire before she joined the Black Widow
program the father that red skull is
talking about Ivan is her first adoptive
father number four then during the Black
Widow trailer footage Red Guardian
milena and Yelena Belova are the people
who then became her second adoptive
family after that when she was a little
bit older inside the Red Room within the
context of the Black Widow movie Red
Guardian was her surrogate father milena
was her surrogate mother
that obviously Yelena Belova grew close
like sisters with her when they were
both in the program coming up together
so all these people when they're talking
about family being back together again
are not biologically related to each
other that's why red skull says her
father's name was Ivan in red Guardians
real name is Alexei here's the thing
though the same people who wrote Captain
America Civil War and talked about her
going off to find her birth parents
graves also wrote Avengers endgame so
they're the same people that did the
Ivan Easter egg from Red Skull in the
parents graves from Civil War when they
wrote those
scripts they were pulling from the
classic Black Widow Marvel Comics the
original Black Widow stories a totally
different person wrote The Black Widow
movie and made red Guardian her
surrogate father milena her surrogate
mother and is a big comic book change
within the Marvel Black Widow comics Red
Guardian was much closer to black widows
age and for a brief period they actually
got married had a relationship before
she defected to America enjoying the
Avengers number three the reason why
they're changing that for the Black
Widow movie is because they want to
bring that same theme of quote-unquote
family fighting for each other that you
see in the Avengers movies like there
was an Avengers end game trailer that
they released early on where Black Widow
is narrating and says I used to have
nothing then I got this family talking
about the Avengers as her family so the
Black Widow movie is kind of riffing on
that and kind of retconning her
backstory a little because technically
she didn't have nothing before she had
the Avengers she had this family / the
Black Widow movie but because they wrote
The Black Widow movie after they wrote
all these Avengers movies it doesn't
quite make as much sense this is always
a little bit of hand waving for
situations like this and I think it's
mostly because they didn't make the
Black Widow movie when they should have
way back during Marvel phase 2 so number
two had Kevin Feige been allowed to
make all the Marvel movies that he
wanted to make when he wanted to make
them instead of doing ant-man right
after Avengers age of Ultron he probably
would have done black panther instead of
waiting till Marvel phase three and he
probably would have done the Black Widow
movie right after she debuted during
Iron Man 2 in 2010 there was only one
Marvel movie during 2010 nowadays they
released three Marvel movies per year
had it gone down that way we wouldn't be
talking about this now we'd be talking
about some other new character that they
had introduced during avengers endgame
theoretically so number one even
though the Black Widow movie takes place
in the past the way that Marvel and
Kevin Feige are trying to keep it
connected to present-day and push the
MCU forward with new stuff is doing some
new Marvel phase 4 stuff set in
present-day at the end of the Black
Widow movie that's all related to
Thunderbolt Ross the weapons Plus
program the Super Soldier serum and the
Thunderbolts all the Falcon in Winter
Soldier episodes will take place after
they start teasing
that that's why Falcon and Winter
Soldier is being released later this
summer after they released the Black
Widow movie because even though Black
Widow takes place during the pass
they're setting some stuff up for Marvel
phase four I've already done a couple
videos about the weapons Plus program in
its history in the MCU movies a lot of
that starts with the Incredible Hulk
movie and Thunderbolt Ross talking about
how he brought the Super Soldier program
out of the mothballs and has been doing
quote-unquote new work good work he even
had banner working on it with his gamma
research without telling banner what he
was doing
side note that's also how you get to the
Weapon X program the new version of
Wolverine down the line but obviously
this is all very preliminary stuff we're
just starting out with bringing the
super soldier program back that'll all
play out over the course of the Falcon
and Winter Soldier episodes currently
even though it's on hiatus for a couple
weeks because of all the craziness they
will start filming again and they're
still supposed to release the episodes
at the end of August just as a big
update they have not delayed the black
widow movie yet but if Marvel makes some
big announcement I will do a video about
that currently it's still coming out at
the beginning of May but it could get
pushed just a little bit into the summer
if there are any big questions or big
video requests just leave them in the
comments below I'll be doing more Marvel
videos big updates about what's going on
right now
congratulations boogie Tron 3,000 you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everyone click here for all
my other Avengers infinity Saga deleted
scene videos and click here for that
brand new black widow trailer with all
the new taskmaster scenes thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!